16 Kinder wurden gestern getötet immer
wieder wird Präsident Putin sagen dass
es eine russische sonderoperation ist
und man nur militärische Einrichtungen
treffen würde was sind denn unsere
Kinder sind unsere Kinder etwa
militärische Einrichtungen mit welchen
Panzern fahren denn unsere Kinder Putin
hat gestern 16 unserer Kinder getötet
ja und dann stehende Ovationen der
Europaabgeordneten nach dieser
videoansprache des ukrainischen
Präsidenten selensky und damit herzlich
willkommen zu diesem ZDF Spezial Tag 6
im Ukraine Krieg dessen Ausgang
ungewisser denn je der von Russland wohl
beabsichtigte Blitzkrieg mit dem Ziel
Kiew für handstreichartig einzunehmen
die Regierung abzusetzen und dann
Marionettenregime einzusetzen ist
vorerst gescheitert aber was heißt das
schon wenn der Goliath gewaltigen
Nachschub mobilisieren kann um David in
die Knie zu zwingen wird es zu diesem
totalen Krieg kommen oder ob sie doch
noch die Vernunft kommt ein Kriegsende
auf dem Verhandlungsweg zustande das
alles wollen wir ausloten in dieser
Sendung zuvor aber fast Cornelia Donath
die Lage in der Ukraine zusammen
es ist so eine Sache mit der Wahrheit im
Krieg Bildern zu vertrauen ist nicht
immer angeraten diese hier stammen vom
russischen Verteidigungsministerium wann
und wo aufgenommen unklar sie sollen
Erfolge von Putins Truppen zeigen und
dass sie Vorankommen in der ganzen
Ukraine bestätigt werden heute vor allem
Angriffe aus rakelf im Nordosten
Raketen schlagen im Zentrum ein Treffen
Wohnhäuser und Verwaltungsgebäude die
Worte die Präsident selenski für diese
Zerstörung findet russischer Staat
Terrorismus der Leiter der
Regionalverwaltung nennt sie
Kriegsverbrechen und der Bürgermeister
von hakif Völkermord
der heutige Tag zeigt dass das nicht ein
Krieg ist sondern Mord an uns am
ukrainischen Volk das erste Mal in
seiner langen Geschichte muss Rakel das
erfahren
die Beschüsse haben Wohnhäuser getroffen
unschuldige getötet und verstümmelt
wie viele Tote es gibt keiner weiß es
genau mindestens zehn sollen es hier
sein doch die Zahl wird wohl noch
steigen die Menschen suchen Schutz und
Bunkern und dich getränkt in kleinen
Kellern voller Angst
wir sind sehr besorgt es ist sehr
beängstigend hier sind kleine Kinder
alte Menschen und offen gesprochen wir
haben große Angst
noch aber stehe die Verteidigung der
Stadt heißt es von ukrainischer Seite
gut 100 Kilometer von hakif entfernt
soll ein Militärstützpunkt bombardiert
worden sein mehr als 70 ukrainische
Soldaten hätten hier ihr Leben verloren
so der Gouverneur der Region auf
Facebook
aus dem Donbass kommen diese
Symbolbilder die russische Flagge wird
gemeinsam mit der der Separatisten von
dorniert sie sollen sagen hier gibt es
Erfolge zu vermelden
unser Land kommt zu uns zurück wir haben
lange davon geträumt und jetzt endlich
gelingt es uns mit der Hilfe der
Russischen Föderation was davon stimmt
unklar diese Häuser etwa sollen von
ukrainischen Raketen zerstört worden
sein die Menschen verzweifelt
ich hoffe der ukrainische Staat dessen
Bürger ich bin wird hier wieder
errichtet ich werde hier vermutlich
sterben und das war's dann
die Truppen der Separatisten Rücken
weiter vor das sollen diese Bilder
belegen der selbst ernannte Führer lässt
verkünden bald werde man mariopol
einkreisen
die Hafenstädte im Süden sind seit Tagen
unter Beschuss am Nachmittag verkündet
Russland das ukrainische Militär habe
keinen Zugang mehr zum ersoffen mehr der
Bürgermeister aus mariopol meldet sich
der Strom sei ausgefallen Straßen und
Häuser zerstört Frauen und Kinder Tod
die Stadt bergjanz soll von russischen
Streitkräften eingenommen worden sein
Bilder auf gestern datiert zeigen
Einwohner vor der Stadtverwaltung die
sich den russischen Soldaten
entgegenstellen sie tragen ihre Wut auf
die Straßen rufen
[Applaus]
ist unser Präsident
auch in Kiew für die Lage immer
dramatischer die Hauptstadt ist wohl
noch in ukrainischer Hand doch wie lange
noch die Sirenen heulen
Satellitenbilder zeigen den Vormarsch
der russischen Truppen mehr als 60
Kilometer zieht sich der Militärkonvoi
aus Panzern und Armeefahrzeugen
Bürgermeister Klitschko mit einem
dramatischen Appell
liebe Freunde hier unsere Situation ist
kompliziert der Feind ist nahe der
Vororte der Hauptstadt unsere Armee
kämpft heroisch für unser Land wir
bereiten uns vor Kiew zu verteidigen
baut Barrikaden an den Eingängen der
Stadt
auch 30 Kilometer vor den Toren in irpin
errichten ukrainische Soldaten und
Zivilisten etliche Checkpoints und
Kontrollen versuche den Vormarsch der
russischen Truppen aufzuhalten irgendwie
schalten wir live in die ukrainische
Hauptstadt zu meinem Kollegen Christian
wehrschütz guten Abend
guten Abend er wäre schon sehr wie
stellt sich Ihnen die Lage da am
sechsten Tag nach Beginn der Invasion
bisher haben sich die Kämpfe auf die
Außenbezirke konzentriert und das
Zentrum von Kiew sind der die
Zerstörungen wie in kalkiefer Sport
geblieben aber vor kurzem wurde der
Fernsehturm in Kiel für angegriffen da
gab es eine Vorwarnung auch des
russischen
Verteidigungsministeriums man möge sich
von derartigen Anlagen fernhalten eine
Warnung wohl was der Staat blühen könnte
wenn der Kampf um die Hauptstadt so
weitergeht wie bisher den bisher sind
die Russen nicht wirklich vorangekommen
was heißt das für die Einwohner von Kiew
für gestern hat uns eine Ukrainerin die
aufs Land geflohen ist erzählt Männer
würden jetzt zum Teil wieder nach Kiew
zurückfahren mit Proviant für Freunde
Familie Angehörige die in der Hauptstadt
geblieben sind können Sie das bestätigen
werden Lebensmittel knapp in Kiew
gar keine Frage das Lebensmittel gehabt
wir haben es ist logisch denn es ist nur
mehr eine Seite offen das ist vom Süden
her da waren wir heute da haben wir
einerseits abseitsbewegungen von der
Bevölkerung raus auf der anderen Seite
haben wir natürlich auch den Versuch
etwas in die Stadt zu bringen und wir
waren ja auch in Lebensmittelgeschäften
und sehen wie die Regale leer werden es
fehlt aber nicht nur ein Lebensmitteln
was auch entscheidend ist es fällt zum
Beispiel auch an Treibstoff und das
macht es natürlich noch viel schwerer
für Zivilisten die raus wollen auch
rauskommen zu können denn einen Fahrer
oder einen Auto finden Sie noch aber
Benzin und Diesel wird schon sehr
verstärkt das was sie gerade beschrieben
haben die Fluchtbewegungen raus aus der
aus der Hauptstadt den Westen oder ist
das tatsächlich eher ein Hemdes für
Menschen die jetzt hier verlassen wollen
nun natürlich ist es auf der einen Seite
ein Hemmnis auf der anderen Seite haben
Sie eine größere Fluchtbewegung geht man
versucht jeden Zug zu erwischen der aus
der Stadt raus führt aber es wird nicht
mehr viele Möglichkeiten geben es gibt
ein zwei humanitäre und Konvois die
bereits wegfahren aber dort können sie
nur mitfahren wenn Sie ein Auto haben
und Sprit und das alles auch beeinflusst
natürlich von der militärischen Lage die
ja eigentlich immer näher an die
Hauptstadt heranrückt der Berater von
Präsident selensky spricht heute von
einem Belagerungsring den russischen
Truppen um Kiew ziehen würden
Satellitenfotos zeigen ja gerade im
Norden auch kilometerlange russische
militär-konvoice worauf macht sich die
Hauptstadt jetzt gefasst
die Hauptstadt muss sich sicher darauf
gefasst machen dass mit viel größerer
Härte mit Artillerie gewisse symbolische
politische oder andere Ziele beschossen
werden und sie wird sich auch darauf
gefasst machen müssen dass wirklich
versucht wird die Belagerung einzuleiten
bzw schneller ins Zentrum vorzustoßen in
welcher Form auch immer auf jeden Fall
Kiew stehen sehr ungute und sehr
schwierige Tage und Wochen bevor wenn es
nicht doch zu noch einen zu einem
Waffenstillstand käme und der
ukrainische Außenminister Kollege sagt
heute man sei bereit zu verhandeln aber
nicht bereit einfach russischen
Ultimaten zu folgen die zweite
Verhandlungsrunde soll der bereits in
den nächsten Tagen vielleicht sogar
schon morgen stattfinden er wäre schön
danke für diese Einblicke nach Kiew
ja wir einen Einblick in die Denkweise
des Kremls suchte der musste heute nur
dem russischen Außenminister oder dem
Kreml Sprecher zuhören keine Spur von
Einsicht oder gar Umkehr im Gegenteil
lavrov und pescov sponnen in gewohnter
Manier das putinische narrativ die
Invasion sei eins der Selbstverteidigung
die Ukraine würde die Zivilbevölkerung
als menschliche Schutzschilder
missbrauchen der Westen arrogant und in
einem russlandfeindlichen Rausch Signale
der Entspannung sehen anders aus während
in der Bevölkerung die Anspannung wächst
vielleicht ist es das Harmloseste was
ein Mensch tun kann aber die Menschen
die hier Blumen niederlegen gehen dabei
ein großes Risiko ein Russen vor der
ukrainischen Botschaft in Moskau sie
wollen Zeichen setzen
ich bin hier um Unterstützung zu zeigen
für die Menschen in der Ukraine ich weiß
aber nicht ob das unsere Führung
beeinflussen wird um diesen Bruder Krieg
zu beenden
ich bin gekommen um meine Anteilnahme zu
zeigen für die Menschen die in dieser
militärischen Auseinandersetzungen in
der Ukraine gefangen sind
Putins Krieg ist weit weg von Moskau und
doch ist er auch hier angekommen bei
Menschen und Banken die Sanktionen des
Westens greifen psychologisch vor allem
der Rubel gestern abgestürzt um 30
Prozent viele fürchten um ihre
Ersparnisse oder das westliche
Konsumgüter schon bald nicht mehr
erhältlich sind riesige Schlangen vor
den Geldautomaten
ich habe Angst dass die Regierung alles
Geld einzieht oder dass die Bankkarten
eingefroren werden ich habe es schon an
verschiedenen Automaten versucht immer
Schlange gestanden den zweiten Tag jetzt
die Sorgen der einfachen Russen für die
hinter den hohen Mauern des Kreml
spielen sie wohl gerade keine Rolle der
Präsident ein Kriegsherr geächtet
sanktioniert aber derzeit auch irgendwie
unsichtbar und schweigend Putin schickt
Sprecher vor um diesen Krieg der
angeblich gar keiner ist den Landsleuten
zu erklären
heute dank der Verteidigungsminister den
russischen Truppen für ihre
Heldenhaftigkeit die spezialoperation
werde fortgesetzt alle gesetzten Ziele
werde man erreichen
ihr Ziel ist Frieden Demonstranten in St
Petersburg die Staatsmacht greift durch
wieder Verhaftungen mittlerweile sind es
über 7.000 dennoch die kriegsunlust
unter den Russen wächst
Menschen sterben Menschen leiden es gibt
Zerstörung niemand kann ihnen ihr Leben
zurückgeben herzen werden gebrochen der
Hass aufeinander wird doch nur von
Generation zu Generation weitergegeben
die Demonstranten eine Minderheit in
putinsreich noch funktionieren
Propaganda und Einschüchterung vom
Kriegsverlauf wird abhängen wie lange
noch
und den Sorgen der einfachen Russen
stehen die Sorgen der Oligarchen
gegenüber Christian Semm in Moskau
einige dieser Oligarchen haben Putin ja
gestern in einem offenen Brief
aufgefordert den Krieg in der Ukraine zu
beenden wie gefährlich können eben die
Milliardäre werden
ja ich würde sagen das ist schon
bemerkenswert erstmals erstmal ist man
es in Russland nicht gewohnt dass es
öffentliche Kritik gibt und dann noch
von solchen mächtigen Menschen in
Russland die ja auch sehr vom System
Putin profitiert haben und jetzt aber
auch unter den Sanktionen leiden
insofern ja haben sich da einige
entschlossen das öffentlich anzusprechen
noch insgesamt aus der Wirtschaft gibt
es langsam so leise Kritik am Vorgehen
denn die Sanktionen trifft natürlich die
Wirtschaft sehr massiv wenn man überlegt
in welchem Volumen teilweise
international internationale Firmen ihr
Investment hier abziehen internationale
Mitarbeiter Russland verlassen mit ihren
Familien
Produktionen eingestellt werden
Auslieferung eingestellt werden das
nimmt dann Ausmaß an was die Wirtschaft
hier noch sehr sehr hart treffen wird
vom Adressaten dieses Briefs der
Oligarchen nämlich von Putin dem
Oberbefehlshaber der Streitkräfte ist
doch erstaunlich wenig zu sehen in
diesen Tagen könnte das mit den bislang
eher mageren Erfolgen im ukrainefeldzug
zusammenhängen
das würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen
wladimir Putin hat sich eigentlich seit
Beginn der Pandemie recht rar gemacht
hat viel
per Video gemacht per Videoschalte mit
seinen Ministern geredeten seinen
Ministerien geredet nur wenig
öffentliche Auftritte dabei ist er jetzt
geblieben er hat wohl große Sorge sich
mit Corona zu infizieren wenn es Treffen
gab auch öffentliche Termine hier zum
Beispiel wie die
Jahrespressekonferenz vor einiger Zeit
da gibt es ein großes Prozedere von PCR
Tests von 3 PCR-Tests an verschiedenen
Tagen und noch eine Art Corona Schleuse
wo die Gäste dann benebelt werden also
hat er sehr große Sorge mit Corona in
Kontakt zu kommen wir haben das in der
letzten Zeit ja auch erlebt wenn ihr
internationalen Staatsgäste waren die
sich dann im Kreml noch PCR-Tests
unterziehen mussten und das dann
verweigert haben da sind dann die Bilder
entstanden mit diesen langen Tischen
also das würde ich jetzt nicht über
interpretieren dass er da öffentlich
nicht so sichtbar ist mal sehen in
welcher Frequenzen mit welchen Inhalten
der russische Präsident der komplette
Kriegsherr in den nächsten Tagen an die
Öffentlichkeit tritt einstweilen vielen
Dank nach Moskau Christian Semm und wir
wollen das Thema vertiefen mit
bundeswehr-general AD Egon Rams den ich
herzlich in Düsseldorf begrüße guten
Abend
guten Abend also Russland scheint ja den
Krieg nun aus der Tiefe zu nähren wie
die militärsagen also Nachschub zu
mobilisieren die kilometerlangen Konvois
von Panzern und zu Militärfahrzeugen
nördlich von Kiew zeugen davon was steht
dazu befürchten für die nächsten Tage
also ich gehe davon aus dass diese
konvoice nicht nur logistische Konvois
sind sondern auch convois sind mit den
Kampftruppen sprich Kampfpanzer
Schützenpanzer und andere schweres Krieg
Gerät nachgeführt wird 64 km Konvoi ist
eine ganze Menge an Fahrzeugen und ich
gehe davon aus dass diese Kampftruppen
neu in das Gefecht eingeführt werden als
nächste Welle um auf diese Art und Weise
den Angriff weiter fortsetzen zu können
denn offensichtlich war hier die
Verteidigung der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte recht erfolgreich und
gleichzeitig nehmen russische
Streitkräfte ja auch Kiew und Harke im
Osten des Landes mit Artillerie und aus
der Luft unter Beschuss ist das jetzt
die erwartete Massierung die
Intensivierung des Krieges von
russischer Seite aus
also es scheint die Intensivierung des
Krieges von russische Seite aus zu sein
und sie geht auch jetzt nicht mehr an
der Zivilbevölkerung vorbei was man in
den ersten Tagen offensichtlich
zumindest versucht hat das lässt darauf
schließen dass die Russen nach wie vor
nicht die Erfolge haben die sie sich
erhofft hatten oder die von ihrer
Planung her vorgesehen waren und von
daher dass es eine leider sehr
bedauerliche Konsequenz wird der Krieg
jetzt auch für die zielbevölkerung
schwieriger und schmutziger das heißt
auch Wohngebiete und Innenstädte geraten
jetzt doch vermehrt unter Beschuss
gerade in hardiff gibt es dafür aus
Sicht des Generals der sie sind eine
militärische Rechtfertigung oder ist das
einfach ja blanker Terror gegenüber der
Zivilbevölkerung
nein das ist es gibt dafür keine
militärische Rechtfertigung wir sind ja
auch in als Soldaten in Einsatzfällen
oder im Krieg wenn das humanitäre
Völkerrecht und dann die Humanität sage
ich gebunden und das wird offensichtlich
jetzt beginnen durch die Russen verletzt
weil sie sich offensichtlich durchsetzen
wollen und weil sie möglicherweise auch
erreichen wollen dass die Bevölkerung
nicht mehr hinter ihren Streitkräften
steht die bisher so gut gekämpft haben
und trotzdem kommt der russische
Vormarsch in den letzten 24 Stunden
offen da kaum voran dass jedenfalls
berichtet der britische Geheimdienst
Hintergrund sollen logistische Probleme
sein wenn das stimmt haben die Russen
ihre Versorgungslinien in den
vergangenen Tagen beim Vorstoß
überspannt
also eigentlich aufgrund der Entfernung
die die russischen Streitkräfte bisher
zurückgelegt haben nicht von daher
müssen sie tatsächlich Probleme haben
mit der Logistik ob sie nicht genügend
bereitgestellt haben zu Anfang ob sie
nicht damit gerechnet haben dass der
Krieg so lange dauern würde wie er jetzt
bereits dauert ich vermute letzteres
denn die Fahrzeuge die Panzer die
Geschütze verbrauchen täglich
Betriebsstoff die verbrauchen Munition
und wenn Sie diese Mengen an Munitionen
Betriebsstoff verbrauchen bzw
verschossen haben dann muss der
Nachschub da sein man hatte sich das
Ganze glaube ich etwas schneller
vorgestellt und etwas erfolgreicher
vorgestellt und man ist halt eben auf
ein sehr hartnäckigen Gegner in der
Verteidigung gestoßen das heißt bisher
ist es auch nicht gelungen die
Lufthoheit zu erringen und das obwohl
Moskau die weltweit zweitgrößte
Luftwaffe besitzt auch das spricht Bände
und wirft natürlich die Frage auch wenn
wie weit sich die russischen
Militärstrategen derart verkalkulieren
konnten Herr Rams danke für diese
Analyse wie immer größer nach Düsseldorf
gerne herzlichen Dank
ja es ist ein Krieg der eigentlich alles
auf den Kopf stellt nur einer tut so als
habe Russlands Aggression keinerlei
Konsequenzen zu zeitigen Altkanzler Gert
Schröder hält an seinen gut dotierten
Posten bei russischen Energiekonzernen
fest die vier Mitarbeiter in seine
Bundestagsbüro haben jetzt darum gebeten
in anderen Funktionen tätig sein zu
können für die einstmals von Schröder
regierten Bundesbürger könnte es indes
noch ziemlich ungemütlich werden die
Inflationsrate schon bei über fünf
Prozent im Februar die Energiepreise auf
höchstem Niveau die Füllstände der
Gasspeicher dagegen im Keller man soll
die Versorgung Sicherheit Deutschlands
künftig über eine nationale gasreserve
garantiert werden das
Wirtschaftsministerium plant ein
entsprechendes Gesetz aber für besorgte
Verbraucher und Unternehmer kommt das zu
spät
ohne Holz geht es nicht im
Einrichtungshaus von Klaus Mehnert doch
ausgerechnet der wichtigste Rohstoff der
Möbelindustrie ist im vergangenen Jahr
deutlich teurer geworden über 60%, die
Inflation deutlich spürbar die
Hersteller ziehen die Preise weiter an
es hat eigentlich die volle Breite hat
erwischt und da waren im letzten Jahr
waren da nicht die üblichen einmal eine
neue Preisliste es kam eine neue
Preisliste und nicht lange danach die
Entschuldigung wir müssen noch mal
nachlegen Klaus Mehnert muss die höheren
Kosten an seine Kunden weitergeben damit
kommt die Inflation wie in vielen
Lebensbereichen direkt beim Verbraucher
an
wenn das so wenn Gehalt gleich bleibt
und man gibt mehr Geld aus man bleibt ja
nichts übrig aber ich denke schon dass
sich viele jetzt Sorgen weil es bis zum
gewissen Punkt dann einfach noch
bezahlbar ist und dann irgendwann nicht
mehr ich bin Musikerin vom Beruf ich
komme von einer Lage nicht so easy
sozusagen seit zwei Jahren und es ist
sehr hart für alle und besonders für uns
und es ist noch schlimmer wenn das alles
abgeht mit dem Preisen im Februar lag
die Inflation nach vorläufigen Zahlen
bei
5,1%. damit bleibt sie auf hohem Niveau
und das sind vor allem mit den
Energiepreisen zusammen zuletzt waren
die Energieimporte über 144% teurer als
im Vorjahr und das war noch vor dem
Krieg in der Ukraine die jüngste
Eskalation sorgt für neue Preissprünge
der Preis für ein Barrel Öl liegt
erstmals seit vielen Jahren wieder
deutlich über 100 Dollar und auch Gas
wird teurer die Chemieindustrie warnt
bereits vor einer Preisexplosion die
Branche benötigt besonders viel Energie
Russland beteuert zwar das sein Gas
weiter fließe doch die Unsicherheit
wächst
ungefähr die Hälfte unserer Gasimporte
beziehen wir aus Russland und wenn Putin
jetzt in dieser Krisensituation
entscheiden würde uns den Gashahn
zuzudrehen dann drohte eine Energiekrise
dann könnte es auch zu einer Rezession
kommen also von daher war es fahrlässig
sich so ein Abhängigkeit zu begeben von
russischen gasimpern und genau deshalb
will die Bundesregierung unabhängiger
von Energieimporten werden das kündigte
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck an der zu
Gesprächen nach Washington gereist ist
Russland habe die Preise so der Vorwurf
strategisch nach oben getrieben wir
versuchen jetzt auch ich in Personen so
schnell wie es geht uns breiter
aufzustellen also die Möglichkeiten zu
diversifizieren wie es immer in der
politischen Sprache heißt aber vor allem
wegzukommen von fossilen Energien dass
die Versorgungssicherheit auch viele
Verbraucher umtreibt spürt der
Unternehmer Theo Baumstark zur Zeit
besonders er verkauft unter anderem
Heizungen seit Ausbruch des Krieges
melden sich immer mehr Menschen bei ihm
offenbar auf der Suche nach Alternativen
für Öl und Gas
natürlich trifft uns als Handwerker der
mit Heizung zu tun hat extrem wir haben
Gasfeuerung wir haben Ölförderung wir
haben auch feststofffeuerung zum Teil
was ich aber gezielt merke jetzt gerade
in diesen paar Tagen das gezielt
Anfragen zu Wärmepumpe kommen und zu
Pellets Heizung also zu zu Ersatzheizung
weil man halt denkt ich kann es leichter
bekommen
viele hatten gehofft dass sich die
Wirtschaft nach dem corona-schock erholt
der Krieg in der Ukraine zeigt aber
Deutschland und Europa sind nicht nur
politisch betroffen die wirtschaftlichen
Folgen sind bisher kaum absehbar
ja dieser Krieg stößt viele Gewissheiten
um und Debatten an die wir vor kurzer
Zeit so noch nicht hätten führen können
oder wollen nehmen wir das Beispiel eine
allgemeine Dienstpflicht für junge Leute
als die damalige CDU-Chefin Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer im November 2019 genau
dies vorschlug schlug ihr vor allem
Kritik entgegen mit Zwang und Pflicht
lasse sich nur wenig erreichen hieß es
damals aus der SPD die FDP bemängelte
eine solche Dienstpflicht würde gegen
das Grundgesetz verstoßen zwei Jahre und
einen russischen Angriff später ist die
Debatte wieder da und einstige Kritiker
scheinen gar nicht mehr so abgeneigt
Thomas münden
so war es von 1955 bis 2011 junge Männer
die nach dem Ende der Schulzeit als
Wehrpflichtige zur Bundeswehr mussten
Grundausbildung kein Zuckerschlecken
dann 18 Monate Dienstzeit auch als schon
lange Frauen in der armee-dienstdaten
hieß es noch entweder Bundeswehr oder
Zivildienst wenn auch nur noch für ein
Jahr lang
2010 dann gab der damalige
Verteidigungsminister Karl Theodor zu
Guttenberg die Aussetzung der
Wehrpflicht bekannt man könne so viele
Soldaten nicht mehr gut genug ausbilden
meinte er
das ist ein Modell das am Ende des Tages
ja deutlich machen wird dass die
Bundeswehr kleiner werden wird sie wird
allerdings auch besser werden seitdem
sind nur noch die beim Bund die wollen
insgesamt rund 180.000 Soldaten tun
aktuell Dienst nachdem jetzt die
Diskussion um den Zustand der Bundeswehr
derart Fahrt aufgenommen hat wünschen
sich einige eine allgemeine
Dienstpflicht zurück sowohl bei der
Bundeswehr als auch im hilfs- und
Pflegedienst unabhängig vom Geschlecht
ich setze mich seit Jahren für ein
gesellschaftsjahr ein für Schulabgänger
junge Frauen junge Männer ein Jahr ob
Bundeswehr aber nicht nur und das ist
wichtig sondern auch soziale Dienste
Hilfsorganisation THW Feuerwehr Vereine
dass sie lernen dass es soziale
Kompetenzen gibt dass sie lernen dass es
nicht nur recht in einem Staat gibt
sondern auch Pflichten und es würde
unserer Gesellschaft richtig gut tun das
ist mir Personal an all diesen Orten und
bei der Bundeswehr braucht scheint klar
wir gehen im Moment von 203.000 Soldaten
im Ziel aus zurzeit sind wir etwa bei
180.000 rundherum das heißt wir haben
noch ein Stück des Weges zu gehen und
insofern wollen wir an diesem Ziel was
wir uns gesetzt haben auch unverändert
festhalten was sagen die um die es geht
zu solchen Plänen an der Düsseldorfer
Heinrich-Heine-Universität gibt es
differenzierte Meinungen
früher habe ich mal davon abgesehen ich
habe mir eigentlich so nee ist nicht so
cool weil das kostet halt viel
Lebenszeit die einem quasi genommen wird
mittlerweile muss ich sagen unter
anderem Tracht unserer Bundeswehr die
wir gerade haben und sage ich mal den
der nicht genügend Kapazitäten sage ich
mal das vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt
von Bauchgefühl her ohne jetzt eine
klare Meinung zu haben würde ich sagen
ich werde nicht abgeneigt aber habe wie
gesagt keine klare Meinung dazu ich
fände es nicht so gut ich finde dass
jedem das selber überlassen bleiben
sollte ob man sich dazu bereit erklärt
oder nicht ein reines Wehrpflicht so die
aktuelle Verteidigungsministerin wäre
auch nicht die richtige Entscheidung ich
glaube das ist wirklich etwas was man
wenn dann auf breitere Füße vielleicht
ein allgemeines Engagement für diesen
Staat aber als reine Wehrpflicht würde
ich momentan nicht unterstützen die
Diskussion um eine allgemeine
Dienstpflicht hat gerade erst begonnen
auf jeden Fall müsste das Grundgesetz
dafür geändert werden
der Generalinspektor der Bundeswehr
Eberhard Zorn stellt die Truppe auf
tiefgreifende Veränderungen ein es
müssten bürokratische Hürden abgebaut
und die Einsatzbereitschaft sichtbar
erhöht werden schreibt Zorn in seinem
heutigen Tagesbefehl und nun nach
unserem Schlenker ins Inland richten wir
unsere Blicke wieder ins Kriegsland
selbst in den Osten der Ukraine wo die
Kämpfe zwischen ukrainischen und
russischen Truppen ja mit dem heftigsten
toben wo der Geschütz Donner schon aus
der Ferne zu hören ist 400 Kilometer
östlich von Kiew in der Millionenstadt
nebrau sind die Menschen voller Angst
der Klang des Krieges jede Nacht ein
nuklearschutzbunker aus alten Sowjet
Zeiten in die niepro 400 Kilometer
östlich von Kiel
es ist eiskalt Alina und ihr Freund Juri
zittern wie alle hier vor Kälte Angst an
Schlaf ist nicht zu denken
wir verstehen nicht warum Russland uns
angreift sie sagen um uns zu schützen
jetzt müssen wir uns verstecken diesen
Schutz brauchen wir nicht
eine Schule unweites Bunkers Vorräte für
diejenigen in der Nachbarschaft die sich
nicht mehr ins Zentrum der eine
Millionenstadt trauen
russisch wurde hier gelehrt aus Protest
erklären sie nehmen niemand mehr die
Sprache der Aggressoren in den Mund
noch sind russische Bodentruppen fern
doch sie werden kommen erklärt Juri
IT-Spezialist nun molotow-bombenbauer
putin will uns erobern und kontrollieren
seine Kriegsrede war abscheulich er ist
entschuldigen sie er ist ein Teufel
dort wo der Bodenkrieg schon tobt kämpft
an 13-Jähriger um sein Leben das Kiefer
ogmadit Krankenhaus die größte
Kinderklinik des Landes die Familie
wollte raus aus der Hauptstadt erzählt
der behandelnde Arzt sie geraten unter
Beschuss
sein jüngerer Bruder wurde leider
getötet er selbst hat Verletzungen im
Gesicht erlitten und an der Wirbelsäule
die Prognose aber es schaffen wird
momentan ist es schwer zu sagen
noch ist das Lager des Krankenhauses gut
gefüllt doch ohne Nachschub wird bald
Sauerstoff fehlen
vor der Klinik verzweifelte Familien die
Krebsbehandlung ihrer Kinder gestoppt
doch ohne hat er sechsjährige archion
keine Chance sie müssen nach Polen auch
wenn die Fahrt lebensgefährlich sei
ich habe solche Angst aber ich sehe
keinen anderen Weg wir müssen es tun
flüchten solange möglich Gleis 6 Bahnhof
Lemberg nur Frauen und Kinder schreien
die Polizisten
ein Albtraum Angst erfüllt es sei
schrecklich erklärt die Mutter eines
einjährigen er habe solche Angst
die Grenze zu Polen 80 Kilometer
entfernt und endlich lang die letzten
Meter zum Zug unter den Flüchtenden auch
Austauschstudenten aus aller Welt
ich bin hier nicht mehr sicher habe alle
meine persönlichen Sachen zurückgelassen
betet einfach nur mit uns
für einige die Reise in die Heimat für
andere ins Ungewisse noch ein letztes
Mal dann muss ein Vater loslassen 10
eines Krieges
ja das sind Szenen die Herzen zerreißen
weil sie Familien auseinanderreißen es
sind Bilder die man während sie in
schwarz-weiß gehalten in den Tiefen der
Vergangenheit verorten würde aber diese
Massenflucht die spielt sich in der
Gegenwart ab und stellt auch die
westukrainische Stadt Lemberg with wie
die Ukrainer sie nennen auf eine
existenzielle Probe jeden Tag kommen
tausende Flüchtlinge aus den östlichen
Landesteilen in Lemberg an beobachtet
von meinem Kollegen Armin Körper Armin
ja wie geht Lemberg mit dieser
Herausforderung mit diesen Menschen
Massen muss man ja sagen um
genau es kommen jeden Tag mehrere
tausend Flüchtlinge aus der zentralen
und östlichen Teilen des großen Landes
Ukraine hierher und
die es gibt hier sieben offizielle von
der Stadt Lemberg angereicht
eingerichtete Anlaufstellen darüber
hinaus sind über 100 nicht also 100
kirchliche und über 150 nicht kirchliche
hilfsanlaufstellen hier präsent in der
Stadt das heißt die Menschen tun alles
um den Leuten irgendwie zu helfen einige
versuchen sich in die Westukraine in
kleine Dörfer zu retten und werden da
vermittelt an Familien andere versuchen
es eben über Züge oder mit dem Auto in
die EU-Staaten und die Züge Armin die
mit den Flüchtlingen an die polnische
Grenze fahren die kommen mir dann
umgekehrt mit Hilfsgütern aus Polen und
anderen europäischen Ländern wieder
zurück nach Lemberg was kommt denn da an
Hilfsgütern an und wie werden die dann
weiter ins Landesinnere transportiert
also hin zu den Hilfsbedürftigen
genau das ist eine riesige logistische
Herausforderung hier hier kommen per Zug
vor allem riesige Mengen Hilfsgüter an
und das muss ja auch jemand irgendwie
sortieren also was ist Windel was ist
Wasser was ist Medikamente das passiert
hier und wird dann an Bedürftige
weitergegeben es werden permanent über
Telegramm Gruppen WhatsApp Gruppen
Social Media werden hier
Transportmöglichkeiten gesucht um die
Sachen weiter ins Land zu bringen in
stärker vom Krieg betroffene Region und
noch zum Glück ist das Kriegsgeschehen
in Lemberg rund 500 km entfernt bereiten
sich die Lemberger trotzdem darauf vor
auch ihre Stadt gegen die Russen
verteidigen zu müssen
also man spürt hier in der Stadt eine
wachsende Anspannung hier sind immer
wieder hören wir Sirenen es wird per
Lautsprecher dazu aufgerufen sich in
Sicherheit in Schutzräume zu begeben der
Grund ist das Lemberg von strategischer
Bedeutung ist dass es einer der letzten
intakten Flughäfen die das Land noch hat
und den will man hier natürlich
verteidigen und befürchtet dass der aus
der Luft angegriffen werden kann dadurch
ist Lemberg schon durchaus ein Zentrum
dieser gesamten hilfs- und
Militäroperation geworden in der Ukraine
und auch am Tag sechs der Angriffe ist
Lemberg für jeden hier sichtbar eine
Stadt im Krieg eine Stadt im Krieg und
keine Stadt mehr in die Touristen kommen
wie wird das kommentiert in der Stadt
genau der Bürgermeister hat heute
offiziell dazu aufgerufen dass ihr keine
Touristen mehr sind und das niemand hier
als Gast sein kann dass die Menschen die
hier sind die hier durchlaufen entweder
Opfer sind oder Helfer und diese Rollen
auch annehmen müssen eine ehemalige
Touristenhochburg die nun hofft vor
weiteren Zerstörungen verschont zu
bleiben Armin vielen Dank für diese
Beobachtungen live im schon dunklen
Lemberg
er seit Beginn des russischen Angriffs
sind ja rund 400.000 Menschen aus der
Ukraine nach Polen geflüchtet das hat
heute auch der Außenminister bestätigt
das sind natürlich überwiegend Frauen
und Kinder den Männer im werfähigen
Alter die werden ja von der Ukraine gar
nicht erst aus dem Land herausgelassen
für diejenigen die hinaus dürfen
bedeutet dies zunächst oft tagelanges
Warten an der Grenze
endlich in Polen sie sind erschöpft
ausgehungert die Flüchtlinge mussten auf
ukrainischer Seite ausharren bei
Minusgraden viele Stunden doch wer es
schafft nach Polen dem schlägt eine
Welle der Hilfsbereitschaft entgegen
polnische und ukrainische Helfer seit an
seit wievartig Ukraine
wir sind einfach gekommen um unseren
Leuten zu helfen wir wohnen in Polen sie
sind aus Krakau ich bin aus Oppeln die
Männer aus Warschau von überall
schauen ob wir es war jeden so es ist
ihre erste Station raus aus dem Krieg
tausende kommen an am Grenzbahnhof und
chemische in Polen darauf haben die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge hingefiebert
die Angst dass etwas passiert auf
ukrainischer Seite war immer dabei
endlich in Sicherheit und Hilfe in
dieser Situation
wir bedanken uns sehr bei allen für das
Verständnis für das Gute Herz
meine Familie ist noch dort ich kann
nicht mehr sprechen
Organisationen Behörden Privatleute
helfen viele Polen bieten kostenlos
Transport und Unterkunft an für die
Menschen aus dem Nachbarland mit denen
man sich seit Jahren verbunden fühlt und
mit denen man einen gemeinsamen Feind
hat Putin wütet in der Ukraine Sorgen
kommen auf die längst vergessen Schienen
Russland das ewige Schreckgespenst
Polens
wissen wir denn dass wir nicht auch bald
in dieser Situation sind auch fliehen
und Hilfe suchen
Millionen Ukrainer leben und arbeiten
bereits in Polen viele Flüchtlinge
kommen jetzt bei Verwandten unter die
nach der krim-krise 2014 flohen im
Moment kommen vor allem Frauen und
Kinder
mein Mann hat uns zur Grenze gebracht
und ist in die Ukraine zurückgekehrt er
ist zurückgekehrt und kämpft in der
Freiwilligen Armee um unsere Stadt zu
verteidigen
Angst große Angst es ist wahrscheinlich
das Atomwaffen eingesetzt werden das ist
die größte Angst jetzt
Polen rechnet mit Millionen Ukrainern
die kommen das Land an sich nicht
besonders offen für Flüchtlinge zeigt
beim Nachbarn eine echte
Willkommenskultur und ist fest
entschlossen zu helfen
der deutsche Städte und Gemeindebund
rechnet mit einem starken Zustrom an
Kriegsflüchtlingen aus der Ukraine nach
Deutschland zunächst würden die
Flüchtlinge zwar die Nachbarstaaten also
Polen oder Rumänien erreichen in
absehbarer Zeit könnten aber deutlich
mehr als 100.000 Menschen auch in
Deutschland ankommen sagt
Hauptgeschäftsführer Gerd Landsberg
knapp sieben Jahre liegt die sogenannte
flüchtlingskrise nun zurück und nun
steht ein Szenario bevor das Bund Länder
und Kommunen ein weiteres Mal fordert
und für 2015 wie heute geht ohne
Solidarität ohne private Initiative wird
es nicht gehen und zum Glück gibt es die
bereits
sie haben es geschafft sind den
Sicherheit endlich Anja manukina ist aus
der Ukraine geflohen mit ihrem
achtjährigen Sohn Nikita und der
fünfjährigen Milana vier Tage waren sie
unterwegs
1700 Kilometer haben sie zurückgelegt
als den skitourier im Norden des Landes
die ersten Bomben fielen
Matratze wir haben Matratzen Decken und
Kissen von zu Hause mitgenommen und auf
die Ladefläche des Transporters gelegt
dann sind wir zur polnischen Grenze
gefahren
meine größte Angst war dass der Bus
abgeschossen wird dass wir von einer
Rakete getroffen werden ich hatte
einfach Angst dass wir da nicht lebend
rauskommen na spusche moschels grillate
Abos kinotte Bombo i prestovember
doch es gelingt mit Hilfe von Freunden
auch aus Deutschland die kleine Familie
findet Zuflucht bei Margarita lebetkina
und ihrem Partner Zimmer fayebirokov in
Münsterland
Margarita stammt aus Russland
zimmer-fee aus Belarus dass die beiden
Anja und die Kinder aufnehmen ist für
sie eine Selbstverständlichkeit
schließlich ist dies nicht ihr Krieg
ich bin selber auch Russen es ist ganz
schrecklich was jetzt passiert und was
meine Land war sie veranstaltet und
damit zusätzlich auch ein Zeichen dass
die Russen nie so schlimm sind nicht
alle Russen denken so und wir wollen
helfen
ja wir sind alle Menschen uns gibt es
keinen Unterschied zwischen Russen
Ukraine
die Nachrichten verfolgen Sie gespannt
aber auch mit großer Sorge ein schönes
Ende des Krieges ist jedenfalls nicht in
anja hat Angst um ihre Eltern die in der
Ukraine geblieben sind
meine hübsche Leute
meine Mama und mein Papa sind in der
Ukraine geblieben
meine Mama möchte auch in der Ukraine
bleiben und nicht fliehen mein Papa ist
in dem Alter in dem er nicht fliehen
darf und meine Mama würde meinem Papa
nie alleine lassen
ich habe Angst um ihr Leben ja
die Russin Margarita tut was sie kann um
Anja und ihren Kindern ein bisschen
Normalität zu geben und ihnen manchmal
noch eine Freude zu machen diese
Hilfsbereitschaft von einer Russin und
ihrem Partner aus Belarus Anja ist
überwältigt
[Musik]
dass wir hier sein können zeigt so viel
Herz und das was man im Herzen hat ist
viel wichtiger als die Nationalität der
Krieg ist nicht von den Menschen gewollt
sondern von den Politikern
dass
es Gefahr für uns alle hier in Europa
man weiß nicht wer wann das Ende haben
wird und was für Ende
und Minister was wir machen können jetzt
die leiten die Leute so helfen
denn ganz gleich ob aus der Ukraine
Russland oder Belarus diesen Krieg hat
hier niemand gewollt
auch in anderen Teilen Deutschlands ist
die Hilfsbereitschaft groß in Potsdam
bringen Einwohner Spenden für die
Ukraine Wasser warme Kleidung
Hygieneartikel Organisator Paul
Malinowski ist überwältigt
wir wollen einfach helfen sogar Kinder
hat seinen Lieblingsspielzeug gestern
hatte abgegeben ich habe im Wechsel
gesagt Louis willst du das wirklich
abgeben und er meinte ja wie die Kinder
in Ukraine ist schon Wahnsinn man macht
das mit dem Herz mit dem Kopf wenn man
das gar nichts tut und sitzt da und
wartet ab das bringt mich
gestern Abend in Potsdam Erleichterung
die ukrainische Pianistin Caterina
Titova begrüßt Freunde aus der Heimat
drei Tage standen sie an der
ukrainischen Grenze jetzt haben sie bei
einer Familie in Potsdam Unterschlupf
gefunden
herzlich willkommen und doch ist die
Sorge groß um die die zurückgeblieben
sind
die letzte Tage waren ja ich glaube
das Schlimmste Tage meines Lebens und
genau an wem ich denken werde ja an an
alle Millionen Menschen die in der
Ukraine noch sind und nicht mehr sind
für sie gebt Katharina ein
Benefizkonzert die Spenden sollen
ukrainischen Familien helfen
zwei Pianisten am Flügel die Ukrainerin
und die russische Kollege gemeinsam in
vollendeter Harmonie
[Musik]
ja die Hilfsbereitschaft in Deutschland
wächst in diesem Krieg über sich hinaus
dafür haben wir gerade eben einige
Beispiele gesehen aber das darf noch
nicht das Ende sein bitte spenden Sie
weiter an das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe
Ukraine die IBAN-Nummer lautet
de65-100-400 600
400 600 alle Informationen auch im
Internet unter Spenden zdf.de oder im
zdf-text auf Seite 890 und dieser Krieg
hat auch Auswirkungen auf eine
europäisch russische Raumfahrtmission
wie die ESA heute mitgeteilt hat wegen
der russland-sanktionen die Mission Exo
Mars nicht wie geplant in diesem Jahr
starten dabei sollen eine russische
Landeplattform und ein europäischer
Rover auf dem roten Planeten landen um
dort nach Spuren von Leben zu suchen
naja vielleicht sollten wir erstmal
unseren verlorenen Frieden in Europa
wiederfinden bevor wir andere erobern
das war unser zdf-spezial das nächste
folgt um 19 Uhr und hier im Programm
geht es jetzt weiter mit der Soko Köln
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
auf der Suche nach einem geheimnisvollen
Grab ich wir beweisen dass es eine
Wikinger Kriegerin gab doch wer ist
Freund und wer ist Feind